Nine,
oh,
2:00 AM on April the 19th,
1995.
That's the moments when 27 year old Timothy Mcveigh exploded his way into the U.
S history books blowing up a gigantic truck bomb outside the Alfred p,
Murrah Federal building in Oklahoma City,
the blast and Nylisa,
the building,
it ended 168 lives,
including those of 19 children.
It also sends a shockwave throughout the nation.
No one could believe such an atrocity was carried out by a fellow American,
especially one has normal seeming as my cafe.
Yeah,
it's Mcveigh's consciousness.
It didn't spring from nowhere.
He was a decorated war veteran,
a second amendment crusader,
and a foreign right activist.
More than that,
he was a product of his time,
a monster born from some of the most controversial actions the federal
government's has ever been involved in acquired loner.
A bullied kid who never fit in Mugabe was the most average by imaginable.
And in the video today,
the story of how that boy became America's deadliest terrorist.
If you drive to upstate New York to the town of Pendleton today,
you'll find a small blue collar community identical to a million others across
America.
There's no historical market here.
That's nothing to commemorate the town that gave birth to Timothy Mcveigh,
born in nearby lockport on April the 23rd,
19,
68.
Young Timothy was the middle child in a household that was as boring as it was.
Dysfunctional.
His father,
Bill works endless shifts,
do support his family,
one,
his mother,
mickey divided his time between going on the road for work and going on the road
with other men.
Years later,
Tim would say that he and his as patty and Jennifer,
so almost nothing of their parents growing up.
Not that the children are isolated,
good Catholics from Irish stock.
The next phase were fixtures at the local church and generally the sort of lines
you'd expect from small town.
Nobody's.
When Mickey finally left in 1978 and took he and Jennifer to live in Florida.
It was just another chapter in that American classic,
the Great Big Book of suburban misery,
but 10 year old 10 being left alone with dad,
bill effectively meant being left entirely alone.
There was nothing to do in pendleton and nobody to do it with,
especially not when you were a lanky intelligence and painfully shy boy,
but nobody seemed to understand.
The only person Tim really connected to in those days was his grandpa.
The two would go shooting together a rare escape from the beatings that Timothy
received at school as he entered his teenage years,
the boy mockingly called noodle by his classmates again to develop a vague
paranoia that the governments might come and take his beloved guns way depriving
him of this one last escape from this miserable life.
It was a feeling that he found reflected in the Turner diaries.
Now,
if you've never heard of the Turner diaries,
you're probably going to have a fairly miserable next 30 seconds.
They were written by a Neo Nazi called William Luther Paris in 1978,
and the book features a white uprising against the Jews and blacks who are
controlling America.
And it culminates in the whites committing a justified genocide.
In short,
the diaries is as a textbook definition of racism as you're ever likely to find
the sort of book Hitler would gobble up for his Nazi breakfast.
Yet it also contains perhaps the key to make these actions.
In one passage,
the heroes detonate a truck bomb outside of federal building,
killing 800 people for 14 year old timothy reading the Turner diaries was like
someone had opened his eyes,
pierced his book,
taps into the deep paranoia.
The young boy was already feeling.
He became a sort of teenage survivalist,
stockpiling food for a nuclear war that was never commons ramping up his
defenses of the second amendment.
Plenty of teenagers though they go through phases of extremist belief only to
later turn into completely normal adults.
And this is something that almost happened to Timothy,
something of a computer whiz.
He graduated high school in 1986 with a partial scholarship.
At this point,
the boy's life.
It could have taken a permanent turn for the ordinary,
but it didn't.
For whatever reason,
Timothy dropped out after two years of bumming around Pendleton.
He made the decision that would change his life and the lives of 168 people
living in Oklahoma City forever.
He decided to join the army.
Yeah,
it was spring of 1988.
When mcvay graduated from boot camp,
I became a paid member of the US military.
Why all accounts?
It was a model soldier.
He even managed to make real friends for perhaps the first time in his life,
pairing up with two guys called Michael Fortier and Terry Nichols like America.
Vein Nichols was a guy from Nowheresville with an absent father like Nichols was
a second amendment advocate with a creeping distrust of the government and like
make a a Nicole's would soon choose to express that distrust through a horrific
violence,
but before we get into that,
we first got to take a quick trip to the Arabian desert.
August the second 1990,
and Saddam Hussein's army rolls into Kuwait,
leaving a trail of horror in its wake.
Ordinary courageous are abducted off the streets,
tortured to death and their bodies and dumped on their families' lawns.
Over 400,000 people flee the country.
Faced with a humanitarian catastrophe,
george h dot w dot Bush orders the US army to create borders along with them as
Timothy Mcveigh now,
a special gunner,
mcveigh was at the head of a column that rolled into occupied Kuwait on January
the 17th,
1991.
He witnessed the fist fighting and the collapse of the Iraqi army firsthand.
Indeed,
he fired one of the earliest shots of the war as his column moved into the
desert and they pulled the trigger on a cannon shot that blue and Iraqi soldiers
head clean off,
although he celebrated at the time.
He later told his official biography is that the image of the men's upper body
disappearing in a spray of red mist came to haunt him as his platoon march,
north along dusty highways and listed with burns out.
Wreckages have destroyed Iraqi vehicles is celebration.
It gave way to horror by the time the war ended on February the 28th,
something inside and they had gone out.
Some vital spark of empathy had gone and it was never to be rekindled.
The next few months were rough for the decorated soldier,
absolutely exhausted by the Gulf War.
Mcvay flunked the army special forces training.
After two days,
he took an honorable discharge and returned to pendleton where you failed to
find steady work,
traumatized and directionless.
He returns to his one real love guns.
In 1991,
the gun show Sackett was a place of itinerant wonder is fanatics and didn't
things he asks.
He lived a nomadic existence,
rooming the empty planes of America and hawking their wares.
Mcvay joins that number,
flogging copies of his childhood favorites.
The Turner diaries do a receptive antigovernment audience.
At some point he made contact again with Terry Nichols,
who left the army on a hardship discharge before the Gulf War.
The two went into business selling army sepsis.
As they spend more and more time together,
they fed fuel into the fire of one another's resentment of the government,
but it would be two major events that would turn those smoldering embers into an
apocalyptic wildfires.
At the same time,
Timothy Mcveigh was becoming desensitized to violence in the Arabian desert and
anonymous man named Randy Weaver was missing his Idaho court date.
A former green baret weaver had taken his wife,
Vicky and that children and retreated into a tiny survivalist cabin overlooking
Ruby creek in 1989.
ATF agents try to turn them into an format when we ever refused.
He was indicted on firearms offenses in February 1991.
He failed to show up at his trial and an arrest warrant was issued on August the
21st 1992 us marshals finally tracked weaver to his cabin.
As they approached,
we've as dark striker started barking.
Fourteen year old Sammy weaver came out of the cabin running with his gun in
hand.
What exactly happened next?
No one knows.
What we do know is that when the dust cleared striker,
Sammy and Deputy Marshal Bill Degan,
they were all debt.
The FBI laid siege to the cabin on August the 22nd FBI sniper lawn hurry,
cheese shot randy as he tried to check on Sammy body,
randy rand for safety.
And how are you?
Chief?
Find again this time his shot missed the window,
randy as Vicky weaver stepped up to the doorway,
her newborn child in her arms,
but it struck her through her head and she died instantly.
The deaths of Sammy and Vicky waiver.
We're like a lightening bolt to the heart of the guns,
second from mcveigh and nickels and others like them.
Ruby Ridge was proof that the government was coming for your guns and that kill
your entire family in order to get them.
It was in the shadow of this tragedy that's an even greater and even more
controversial.
A cod,
and you'll certainly recognize the name of this one because it was Waco on
February the 28th,
19,
93 ATF agents raided the branch Davidians,
religious compound outside of Waco,
after David Koresh was accused of violating firearms regulations.
And if you do want to learn more about David Koresh,
do check out our video about him.
I'm going to link to it in the description below.
Now that rate,
it turns into a massacre that killed four atf agents and six Davidians.
The massacre then turned into a standoff before transforming into a siege.
When the FBI got involved for the next 51 days,
the world watched his waco became a succuss.
The firearms angle drew and protestors from across the country,
and among them was Timothy Mcveigh,
but they joined the crowd of journalists.
Protest isn't rubberneck,
is on a hill three miles from the compounds watching as all the action unfolded.
He hawks nt,
government bumper stickers,
and like many others predicted another Ruby Ridge.
However,
he wouldn't be there to see quite how right he was.
On April the 19th,
the FBI tried to storm the compound instead to the world watched in horror as it
went up in flames.
Billowing black smoke filled the sky hanging in a poisonous cloud above Texas.
To this day,
the is still debate over who started the fire,
but there's no debate over the outcome.
The charred corpses of 75 Davidians were eventually pulled from the rubble among
them.
Twenty five children.
Look,
they watched the Davidians burn live on tv from Nicole says couch on his farm in
Michigan.
Exactly what he felt.
Seeing his darkest fears realized is of course unknown,
but we do know that in the aftermath,
mcgann Nichols began experimenting with building pipe bombs.
They're angry at the government had reached a boiling point,
and the two men began the slow slide toward extremism,
and of course committing horrifying vengeance.
In September of 1994,
President Bill Clinton signed into law the assault weapons ban,
briefly outlawing certain types of firearms coming in the wake of Ruby Ridge and
Waco.
The band was like tossing gasoline onto the fire of anti government propaganda.
Mcgarvey would lay to claim that this was the last straw.
Initially the young extremist.
He hoped to assassinate prominent figures in the federal government among his
dog.
What Attorney General Janet Reno Lawn Hurry,
Archie,
the FBI sniper who'd killed Vicky Weaver at Ruby Ridge,
but this planet soon fizzles getting past and bodyguards was too tricky and
there was no guarantee mcvay would be able to assassinate even a single figure
before being caught.
Instead,
he turns to an unlikely source of inspiration,
Islamic fundamentalism.
The year before,
just three days before the waco siege,
just small Islamist cell had exploded,
a truck bomb beneath the world trade center up.
The boss had been intended to collapse the north tower,
killing hundreds of people in the end,
though it failed to damage the foundations and killed only six people from like
the 1993,
WTC bombing was a source of both inspiration and contempts.
While he was impressed that such a small salad manage to attack such a high
profile landmark,
you considered their attack a failure in later years.
He admitted to studying for bombing obsessively and he vowed that he could do
better.
His first step was to get Terry Nichols involved richer than mcvay and with more
practical knowledge and explosives,
Nichols was necessary for the success of any attack.
So in late September,
mcvay took him to one side and explained his plan together.
The two of them were going to blow up the federal building,
just like in the town of diaries,
and a happier world would have responded by saying,
yeah,
a short end and then immediately alerting the FBI.
But this isn't a happier weld.
The feds,
they were the enemy and Nichols was just as angry and just as ready to lash out
at the government as mcvay was.
So when mcvay said,
let's build a bum nichols.
He simply said,
well,
yeah.
Throughout September,
the slowly began amassing bags of fertilizer.
When they weren't buying,
they were hanging out with our old buddy Michael 40 errands,
setting off pipe bombs in secluded canyons,
biography about mcvay.
They had made a connection who promised to sell them nitromethane a highly
potent racing fuel.
On October the 20th of the Padre have to Dallas,
Texas to pick up a batch on the way they stopped in Oklahoma City.
Today,
a controversy remains over the points at which mcvay decided to bomb the Alfred
p Murrah Federal Building,
some belief the decision was taken in September.
Others believe that wasn't until the morning of the bombing when the original
target have to be scrapped at the last minutes,
whatever the truth,
the FBI's official chronology of Mcveigh's movements in the fall of 1994 states
that he had nichols pulled over outside the Murrah building on their way to
Dallas long after he was arrested,
like they would say,
had originally chosen another federal building in the city,
but had a change of heart when he noticed it.
How is the flower store?
Evidently,
he felt no such reluctance when he saw the Mara Buildings Daycare Center.
It was during the Dallas trip that mcvay got some unfortunate news.
His grandfather had passed away following a long illness.
The man who'd once been young timothy,
his only friend was now gone,
and with that,
I think there's lost connection to the world was severed.
The next few months unfolded in a haze of petty crimes of fertilizers,
stockpiling and mind numbing normalcy.
I think they visited gun shows,
try to hook up with women and even took a vacation.
This building,
this average bustle of life,
something much darker was beginning to take shape.
Nichols by now we're stealing guns to generate funding and the two were slowly
filling countless drums with fertilizer and with fuel as a 1994,
six over into 1995.
Mcvay was making more and more trips to Oklahoma City at least once with 40 year
in tow away from his future target,
though he was starting to dabble and crystal meth and acid as the winter slipped
away into spring mcveigh,
he caught himself off from everyone,
even nichols by April.
He was spending long nights sleeping in his car and lying low in motels at some
point 40 years.
Wife made him a fake id to use for renting vehicles.
The glaze last week as a free man is still shrouded in mystery.
He rented a hotel room in junction city,
Kansas and may have been spotted conversing with still unidentified men at some
point,
a man known as John Doe to allegedly rented the rider truck used in the blast
eye witness accounts of due to fuel conspiracy theories about the bombing to
this very day as Easter Sunday.
Nineteen 95 arrived.
Nichols finally traveled down to Kansas on April the 18th in mcvay,
drove out to Gary Lake with our fertilizer and fuel.
As the sun came up over the water,
they mixed their ingredients together,
creating a highly unstable bomb.
By noon,
they were done.
Mcveigh's said goodbye.
He goes back and the Ryder truck and drove off into the bright spring afternoon.
The next time Nicholas,
how it is old friends name it would be in for this.
On April the 19th,
1995 state Trooper Charlie Hangar was out patrolling the empty highways north of
Oklahoma City when he spotted a car driving without place.
It had been a heavy morning hanging out,
just heard on the radio that some kind of explosion had happened in Oklahoma
City and all the cops in the area were converging on the disaster,
but hangar was nothing if not by the book.
So rather than turn his car around and scream towards the smoke-filled skyline,
he flicked on his lights and pulled over the battered old.
This mercury or gone to young man was sat in the driver's seat.
A common expression on his face as hanging around to see his license.
He noticed a bulge under the young man's jacket he was carrying and illegal
concealed weapon.
Young then followed hang as iron line and gave a tight grin.
My gun is loaded.
Officer,
he said,
so is mine.
Revlite hanger,
Yanking his pistol out and pointing it to the young man's head as hang a
drover's prisoner back towards Perry and the local county courthouse.
He was passed by more vehicles speeding towards Oklahoma city.
It never even occurred to him that he might have the bommer.
Saturn is backseat.
The Oklahoma City bomb had exploded at nine.
Oh,
2:00 AM in front of the Murrah building.
The blasted,
removed the north wing and collapsed all nine floors.
Windows 25 miles away had shaken from the shockwave in the aftermath.
Ordinary Oklahomans that watched in horror as the bloodied corpses of children
were pulled from the huddle,
all told a 168 lives had been snuffed out as news spreads suited.
The suspicion that a foreign power was involved,
the bomb was simply too powerful.
The media broadcast stories about Arab terrorists attacking the heartland grave,
looking spokespeople.
It came on TV and said that was a possibility.
Saddam Hussein,
it actually orchestrated the attack and very courthouse.
Timothy Mcveigh commonly watched these reports unfold.
At that moment.
He was the most wanted man on the planet.
No one had the faintest inkling that he was already in jail on Friday morning,
two days after the bombing,
mcveigh was about to go and see the judge and post bail.
When a forensic FBI operates,
called Charlie,
hanging out to ask if it's traffic violation was still sitting in the cells.
Hang.
I said,
well,
sure.
Keeping there the operator box.
Whatever you do,
do not let him go.
By fluke,
the Ryder trucks axel had been destroyed in the blast,
held two blocks through the air.
It had been recovered with its serial number still intact.
The FBI managed to trace it back to a motel where mcvay had stayed using his
real name and with that the game was up in Perry,
a mob of angry Oklahomans surrounded the courthouse.
Has Federal agents arrested mcvay Sean solve baby killer,
filled the APP as he was dragged out into the media spotlight,
mcvay seemed totally unfazed by the attention.
He simply scans the nearby rooftops,
his eyes flitting from one to the other with an eerie calm.
Mcvay would later say that he was sure and FBI sniper was amounts taken out as
they had with Vicky weaver three years earlier.
That would be bad because he didn't want to die until he told his story until it
explained why he had done it.
It was sure that when the American people heard his reasoning,
they would rise up against the government's.
Just like in the Turner Diaries,
Timothy Mcveigh was indicted on August the 10th,
1995.
Terry Nichols said,
surrender to authorities.
The day that mcvay was identified and was charged as a coconspirator.
Michael Fortier was also arrested and tenant star witness in return for a
lenient sentence of the three men.
Only 40 year would ever tasted freedom again.
In the end of the trial of Timothy Mcveigh took one month,
mcvay instructed his lawyers to use a necessity defense arguing that he was in
immediate danger from the government and the bombing was an act of self defense,
but there's as they refused.
At the end of the trial,
the jury unanimously recommended death by Nathan injection.
Terry Nichols was sentenced to a hundred and 61 consecutive life sentences with
no possibility of parole.
Following Mcveigh's conviction,
do you balance Oklahomans paid to fly the jury out to Oklahoma City and gave
them a vip tour for a brief period after his trial.
Mcvay was incarcerated in Adx,
Florence,
Colorado in a wing known as bombers,
rope a real life Arkham asylum bombers.
Row was already homes the unibomber Ted Kaczynski,
NWTC,
Bama,
Ramsey,
Yousef.
According to one of Mcveigh's biographers,
he and Kaczynski became firm friends bonding over a love of nature.
Yusef meanwhile tried to convert to Islam,
but mcvay politely declined.
Mcveigh's never expressed any remorse for his actions.
And in his biography,
he called the 19 dead children collateral damage.
He maintains that the bombing was a justified response to waco and he wasn't
alone.
The great writer golf,
it all became a pen pal of Mcveigh's and spend the last years of his life
ultimately defending mcveigh's actions.
At one point,
comparing him to an American hero,
Paul Revere,
and suggesting that he was really innocent while mcvay respected at all.
He had no truck with theories that had been framed.
He had carried out in the morning and he wanted everyone to know it.
Look was finally executed on July the 11th,
2001 the day he was put to death.
So many natives of Oklahoma City.
You wanted to watch the monster die,
that a lottery system had to be set up to ration places in the chain.
The the rest wants to fire a satellite link from the very city mcvay had
callously torn the heart out of any six years before at 7:15 AM,
Timothy Mcveigh became the first federal prisoner to be executed since 1963 as a
cocktail of lethal drugs with slowly pumped into a system.
He refused to say a word.
We're very calm.
He simply looked into the camera broadcasting is death to Oklahoma City,
forcing his eyes to stay open even as his heart slowed to a stop.
When he finally died,
his eyes remained fixed on the camera,
as if mocking those that had hurt so much,
but the moment when he died,
it was lost.
A mind of the deadliest attack in US history.
It was the boy next door who read a book and they're determined its plot into a
horrifying reality.
As his heart stopped,
it was on a world in which Americans still feared the government and right wing
terra was the biggest concern of law enforcement.
It was a world that mcvay had helped to create,
but it wasn't one that would last exactly three months after mcvay breathed his
last Islamic fundamentalists smashed planes into the twin towers and the
Pentagon killing 17 times as many as mcvay had in the aftermath of nine slash
seven support for the government surge to its highest level in decades.
Rightwing terror vanished from the headlines,
replaced by the specter of Islamic extremism in the wake of nearly 3000 dead in
New York City.
The bombing of the Murrah building was almost forgotten,
yet mcveigh's still holds a special place in American history.
No domestic terrorist has ever equals of the horrific acts that he carries out
that day and act,
which inspired everyone from the columbine killers to Anders Breivik.
Even today,
he costs along poisonous shadow once again.
Anti government further is on the rise far right.
Extremists like dylan roof and Pittsburgh shooter,
Robert bowers are sewing terror in American communities as the world lurches
back towards a darker place.
It's worth remembering the life of Timothy Mcveigh and the lessons that is awful
crime taught us all.
So I hope you found this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
We got brand new videos just like this twice a week.
So you hit that subscribe button and as always,
thank you for watching.